take odor rizzy on the mound today for
the astros for start back since going on
the injured list you can see he had
three starts this season the number's
not that great for jake looks pretty
good early on in some of those outings
and then faltered around the fourth or
fifth inning showing a little bit of
fatigue but here hopefully healthy fam
like a lot of padres a threat to run
as manny machado digs in manny playing
at third base for the first time
starting in the field since may the 19th
now tip caught by stubs there's a
strikeout for odor rizzy getting machado
for the first half that's a walk to
cronenworth and putting runners on first
and second it makes against a pretty
good hitter and fernando tatis jr
swing and a miss
gets tatis jr for the strikeout second
strikeout in the inning for odaruzzi so
now odorizzi facing eric hosmer back in
the lineup
swings the first pitch sends a fly ball
into shallow right out duvet back for it
makes the play over his shoulder for the
final out of the inning on the mound
today for the padres getting his 11th
start and a padres uniform is you
darvish on here for the astros in the
bottom of the first inning here's chaz
mccormick
swinging a miss and mccormick strikes
out for strikeout of the day for you
darvish so one on one out brings up alex
bregman
swinging a mess he strikes down darvish
got back-to-back case two down
so two outs out two bay at second base
and kyle tucker coming up
jolts it out towards right center field
pro far dives and makes the catch
jerks and profile laying it out in right
center field he robs the astros of a run
profar fully outstretched in right
center field makes the catch
the astros despite hitting him in that
post season in 2017 even correa's
numbers not great against you three for
17 with that home run
he's the only one in this lineup with a
home run against
you darvish
correa drives one deep right center
field towards the astros bullpen and
gone
carlos correa hits a deep home run to
right center field the astros take a two
to nothing lead
got a cutter out over the plate that he
could drive and he did not miss any of
it he got trevor pout trevor bauer on a
slider to put the astros ahead
here he gets a cutter away
elevated out over the plate and just
leans on it
those front hips open up that barrel
falls behind and drives it the other way
that was a beautiful swing from carlos
looks like things are connecting a
little bit better here recently for
carlos correa
with two hits and now two runs
led miss diaz will bat
swinging a miss and he strikes out diaz
10 the inning but the damage has been
done carlos correa with a two run shot
astros leaded two nothing
so after hoping for five innings out of
jake they might get more than that as
will myers taps one slowly to third
great bare hand play by alex bregman to
get myers for the first out of the fifth
inning watch the feet
he'll chop him a little bit to could
have get himself in position to catch
that long hop
and once he timed up that long hop it
was just a matter of making that catch
and turning it into a good throw and
that's exactly what he did to out no one
on for ha sung kim
called third strike outside corner odor
rizzy rolling along a nine pitch inning
jake has retired the last 14 padres
into left field fam broke back now he
comes in straw with great speed he will
score on a sac fly by mccormick his
second sacrifice by the series and the
astros lead three to nothing
loading the bases here in the fifth had
the lead off man on in three different
innings
fragment the white batting gloves ready
and waiting
alex drives one to left field that'll be
down for a hit
bounces off the wall away from fam stubs
will score altuve to third alex bregman
and rbi double it's four nothing
yeah let's see what they do here with
tucker the 1-0 to tucker and that's a
bouncing ball right side to his right
the second baseman boots at cronenworth
picks it up and won't have a play altuve
scores on the ever and the astros lead
grows even further it's five nothing
so bregman to third
tucker at first
and correa stands in he got the scoring
started for the astros with his two-run
homer in the fourth
that is strike three
so it puts it into the inning but not
before the astros tack on three more
take a five-nothing lead at the end of
five
they go to rizzy in his longest start of
the 2021 season his longest is an astro
responsible for the two runners on but
he is five and a third innings in
having not allowed a run in this game a
word with dusty baker before he hands
off the ball and he should get a nice
hand from the crowd here at minimate
park
here's garrett stubbs
around the bunt bun is down taylor jones
will score
garrett stubbs gets the first third
front play down and the astros regain a
five-run lead it's now 6-1
veteran right-hander in here to face to
top the lineup for the san diego padres
19 games this season
slowly hit correa is going to have to
hustle and he will make the play in time
to get tommy pham to end the inning
manny machado leads it off here in the
eighth with joe smith back out on the
hill
machado lifts it to left field down the
line and that ball is going to one hop
the wall
jaz mccormack could get it back in but
machado is to second base with a double
does a split at home plate on a pitch in
how about that flexibility
heck of a move
swing and a miss joe smith gets fernando
tatis junior swinging third strikeout
today for todd thief one out in the
eighth inning and it brings up eric
hosmer
and it's into right field a base hit for
hosmer
machado is going to be waved around he
will score
and the padres make it six to two now
run in for the padres and here's will
myers
grounded left side correa is going to
first and it's late
runels score in from third comes
cronenworth and it's now six to three
ryan presley coming on two on two outs
facing hot sun kim
[Applause]
ground ball towards correa carlos with
the play and that'll do it san diego
scores two they also strand two presley
gets the job done out of the pen it's
6-3
fernando
lifts it in the air foul ground first
base wade jones by the seats and he
can't make the catch
falls backwards and cannot make the grab
the backspin fooled him and fernando
will get another chance tying one of the
plate for the padres
and a 1-1 to fernando
fernando
hits one of the air down the left field
line and is headed towards the pole it
is headed onto the tracks it's a three
run home run
history in houston for fernando tatis
junior with two outs in the ninth the
padres have tied it up six to six
unbelievable
at the corners with nobody out
derrickson pro far
on the ground and going to second for
one on to first it'll be a double play
as hosmer scores
so they elect to go for the dp allowing
the run to come in
carlos correa including the postseason
has more walk-off base hits than anybody
in baseball
there's a base hit towards left field
that'll score a run tucker ties the game
correa to second base rbi double we're
not enough at seven and extras a chance
here for manny machado coming up
machado grounds went through the right
side into right field of base hit from
third base comes kim and the padres take
an 8-7 lead
ball gets away here comes straw we're
tied at eight
chaz mccormick draws a walk
looked like a catchable pitch that got
gets away from carrottini and straw for
the second time this year next running
scores on a pitch that gets away from
the catcher
that'll bring up will myers
myers hits a fly ball to right field
pretty deep tucker back at the wall he
leaps and it's gone
will myers hits a three-run home run and
the padres taking 11-8 lead in the 12th
inning with two outs in the 12th inning
and taylor jones coming up
jones strikes out in the padres win take
game two of the series a three-run home
run for will myers in the top half of
the 12th inning
is the difference in this one as the
padres in 12 win it 11-8